on this episode storytelling superstar
Morgan Spurlock stops by
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this
ask Gary B
[Music]
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 256 of the askgaryvee
show I'm super fired up for this
phenomenal guess it's ironic is really
for some we're jamming yeah we've
interacted a little bit on Twitter yeah
then we ran in to each other our plane
on a plane I was like hey you should
come in oh the best part is like then
you walk by and then I DMD I was like
hey you should be a guest on the
askgaryvee show you're like sure here we
are two weeks later Morgan why don't you
tell the one person from the
vaynernation who doesn't know who you
are how you describe yourself now and
we'll get into this show we're going to
have Facebook if you're watching so what
we're doing taking phone calls from
where Facebook so Instagram peeps go
over to Facebook live if you want to get
your questions in put your phone numbers
into Facebook Morgan and I are going to
take four or five calls depending on how
much we Yap that's right
but for that one-and-a-half person yeah
no I yeah my name is Morgan Spurlock I
am a filmmaker a producer a writer but
mostly I am a professional storyteller
that's what I do that's how you go with
yeah which makes sense yeah so morning
before we go into questions I'm gonna
get some background not to be included
like an amateur story it's really quick
it's really crazy that means I should
get paid once in a while that's the key
all the time but sometimes I actually
get paid for it well you know what it's
funny I think I think professional
storytellers um just get paid right like
I think they can come from anywhere
that's right they make big Hollywood
films or gonna make a Instagram channel
I could be anywhere yeah that's right uh
so take me all the way back when did you
realize you were storyteller were you
the kind of kid that was a movie buff
like oh yeah you want to be Steven
Spielberg when you were told that ever
sick give it to me when I was a kid
growing up in West Virginia I mean for
as long as I can remember I love movies
I love TV
I love the untamed business in general
and all I ever wanted to do was make
movies and I mean first far back as I
can remember five six years old like
that was my that was my dream and and
now here I am you know 41 years later
and it's my life and it's awesome to
kind of see just how this all came to be
so you're 41 years old 46 years old 46
so ft5 guys okay so so what about West
Virginia I don't think that is like LA
Harbor or payme is the hotbed of the
unity of business and this is
now you know service the forty years ago
right thirty-five years ago I had
amazing parents like my mom and dad you
know god bless these guys they are the
great I was just talking to my mom as I
was falling down on your street outside
nice to you by the way thank you outside
there are like giant this giant
construction work there's like a giant
rat like so there's obviously something
going wrong in your buildings a giant
rat outside one join the union it's a
vagina things you needing so I was
talking to my mom right before I came in
but when I was growing up in West
Virginia I had these two amazing parents
that love the Arts were so supportive of
the Arts I was the youngest of three
ballet dancing brothers like Maya that
right yeah my oldest brother Craig went
on to become a professional dancer as
did my middle brother it's cool yeah
it's my favorite not the cool thing to
be doing in West Virginia but an awesome
thing to like have parents that will
support you saying if that's what you
want to do we're on board so what's
interesting about that is my all-time
favorite football players al two minutes
yeah and what he would do in the
offseason is a wide receiver Nate he's
was go I mean it's a football player
yeah and he did ballet and he equates a
lot of his success to that gave me so
much coordination it gave me so much
confidence it made me a much better
athlete
it made you confident because when kids
are like you do ballet you had to figure
out how to rebuttal that's right yeah
it gave me a much better sense I would
usually just make fun of myself of
course for doing it so I think the self
deprecation it's kind of lived on in my
life so what's the first break or what's
the start of your career where do you
what do you how does this happen do you
go to school for it I mean it was what
happened I think was what I got into
film school like I went low as ow okay
first I went to Southern Cal hoping
didn't want into USA you were able to
get into USC got into USC broadcast
journalism which is huge right like you
were like holy [ __ ] like yeah I'm going
to USC yeah I didn't get into the film
school but every semester I kept
applying yeah yeah and every semester I
kept getting rejected yes I'm sorry
they're like you'll never make it that's
what got rejected five times from the
USC film school finally the last time I
was like I gotta apply somewhere else I
keep putting all my eggs in this basket
right and it was a shitty part like
here's what an idiot I was at the time I
wouldn't apply to UCLA just out of
principle right because that foregoing
USU's like I can't go to us yeah what do
I do you say like an idiot yeah because
UCLA's beautiful like like usc's in the
middle of watts like it's yeah like that
download UCLA's over in Westwood the
most beautiful provincial campus ever
but I wouldn't apply there so I applied
to NYU and I got it
Mandie New York been here since 1991 so
he got into NYU never left and so what
happened next well I mean I think in Y
you the best part about this school in
New York City in general is New York
City's really good at trimming the fat
and I think I think it's a great city
that automatically helps you a either
find your place in the business you're
in find your place and what you want to
do or get the hell out or get out and I
and I think the film school also did
that is it really forced me to kind of
come in focus and you know bust my ass
through school and and kind of get what
I wanted we're able to look around be
like oh that fat kids talented she's
talented like going to kind of give you
listen I mean I went to film school with
kids who were infinitely more gifted
than than I was who are infinitely more
talented better story to our DPS artists
like proper artists who are now really
great real estate brokers and really
great accountants you know people who
what do you equate your ability to break
through them what everybody aspire to do
yeah in a world where they didn't
achieve that and you might be like
honestly I gotta be honest because as an
entrepreneur Matt I mean I think a lot
of it it's you mentally I think you I
think it's you're not only willing it
but you don't quit I think quitting is
easy that's the other things a lot of
people give up quitting is the easiest
thing in the world and and I just I
don't know I I just yeah I grew up with
parents amazing parents and were like
whatever you start you finish yeah you
never like no matter what it was like if
I'd wanted to quit baseball they were
like nope you're finishing the whole
season you never I was never able to
quit anything and so I and I grew up you
know with my father who's an
entrepreneur who started a business out
of our garage that grew into a huge
business and so I mean for me it was
always about I've got to stay the course
I've got to see it through so what's the
first break in ms.fer school I mean
first real break there were so many
great ones like right out of film school
like the very first job I ever got was
um being a PA on the professional which
I look back is like being such like
because it was like I was I was being I
was an intern at Robert De Niro's
production company down it to the
Tribeca Film Center at the and I kept I
kept you know badgering all of the other
film productions there you know I can I
get a job is about to graduate
I have no employment my mom and dad are
like you better find a job right when
I've been appreciating we're not going
to be there when I open you better find
a job yeah and so every day I kept going
to the production offices as like hey
are you hiring anybody hiring anybody
finally I went to the was I had two
weeks left in school and like the
production corps
Nader for for Leon was what the films
called at the time the professional what
it became when it came out said Morgan
do you speak Spanish
I said seem yes penniless muy bien and
they said we need a PA who can speak
Spanish I said okay yes I'm your guy so
they hired me so I was like oh my god I
got a job that's fantastic like that the
only sentence you knew in Spain I do a
few more like televideo Tec Emil
opposite I'm a Rio Grande yeah tell me
gusta su perro you know now you're just
bragging but I knew I knew a plate I
knew enough words where I could [ __ ]
my way into it so yeah see about a month
later as we're in production and we're
way up on the Upper West Side in like
Washington Heights and we're shooting a
scene and all said this woman is
screaming at the party music I screaming
at the production coordinator in Spanish
like we need Morgan to come down to the
corner right now she's way come down to
the corner and she's screaming and
yelling and pointing they're like what
is she saying I was like she's really
mad she's that I'm listening I was like
she says you bag along and all of this
is bad need to go you're like you don't
understand we're saying oh I said I'm
understanding pieces they're like get
out of here however by that point I'd
already kind of appreciated my way into
the job so I didn't get fired they kept
me around but you know I didn't quite
tell the hotel the whole truth in my
Spanish buddies and you're so right
right it's always building blocks what
was the big break that is like the
Hollywood headline or the the thing that
I was like in a good time we have to go
away well the biggest the biggest thing
that happens like when we made supersize
me and that went to Sundance me changed
everything like I made him what were you
doing before that right I don't see when
I think back in 1999 I started my first
company yes which was a web-based
company called the interactive
consortium where I was realized in the
middle of the tech boom I should I want
to create a company that produces
programming online yes and then
springboard it off to film or television
understood and so as everybody was
raising money din pseudo pop you be oh
you do icebox yes and these companies
were raising hundreds of millions of
dollars I put together my business plan
we were trying to raise about eight we
had a few people that were on the hook
we're about to close and then March 2000
happen and everything went all the money
went away yep nobody was writing a check
for anything and I was like [ __ ] what do
we do now yeah and there was one guy
that was still interested so I went and
met this one guy in a bar
Marty Garvey who he said who's amazing
good so I win met him in a bar and he
said he goes I
know anything about content because I
don't ever invest in like crazy ideas
because I invest in people and I don't
know if this will work because but I
believe in you and you wrote me a check
for 250 grand in the bar and were you
like what the hell just happened well I
was like I was like was this real
balance like it's just reality goes in
you should put that away and so I folded
it up and put it in my sock and you ask
yourself well how long do I sit and
drink at a bar or somebody just wrote me
a check for $200,000 and the answer is
as long as they want yeah that's right
we stayed in that bar and drank all
night until they threw us out then the
next day I went back to the guys because
I already had people in the office
working on this company they were like
let's that's great let's get started and
so at back in 2000 there were there
there was no reality television that's
right that's crazy to think about that's
right um but there was a gameshow that
had just come back to television called
Who Wants to Be a Millionaire I remember
and anyway and it went from one night a
week to two nights we like I was like it
took over the whole summer took over the
whole summer that's why I'm huge yes I
was spring into summer I said we got to
make a game show and so we made a game
show called I bet you will where I would
go out on the street and get people to
do stupid things for money we launched
the show in May of that year The Fray
online I bet you all calm right by the
way for all the youngsters no YouTube no
social media no you just put up a URL
and it was expensive to suspend me yeah
like literally the first day the site
exploded like word got out like I was
getting picked up by all these TV and
radio stations and doing promos for it
why did that happen because the show was
there wasn't a show nobody was the first
cedar to match did you have a
relationship there like no not really
something somebody had seen it and
literally called like see like we were
out shooting one day in the Village
Voice did a story after seeing a shame
one day um Opie and Anthony when they
were on we're like oh my gosh you have
to see the show that I bought it that's
all you need it and so then they like
monsters they were pet they were huge
and so the show just blew up and the
first day it went alive online we had a
million unique visitors and so Akamai's
calling at the end of the second day and
they're like you got to give us more
money because like there remember like
babies guys from utility wants to serve
these streams by the end of the first
week we had five million streams by the
second week CBS called
and so we ended up selling the show to
them they sat on it for like six months
they'd know what to do with it and then
in that time fear factor came out Big
Brother came out all these bigger
reality shows and so then they're like
well we don't
what to do with it we got the show back
sold at MTV ended up doing 250 are doing
53 episodes for them and then when they
canceled that show in the fall of 2003 I
said well let's take this money and
let's make a movie and we took the money
that we made from that made supersize me
Wow yeah we'll get into that in a little
bit but let's get into the first phone
calls and to get that I mean like
supersize me obviously was the first
time you know I'm some people know this
like Doc's are really the only thing I
consume I love them I grew up on eating
McDonald's so I was super fired up that
was a pretty awesome film and I changed
everything right like you expect
exploded it exploded it is like like
literally within there was a moment at
Sundance I remember Sunday's 2004 when
we were there where and I'd watched
who's this
hold on sure this is how we do it we
interrupt it what's that Mel Mel cool
what signal is no way Oh Mel its Gary B
and learning askgaryvee show with morgan
gary vee holy crap i can't believe i'm
on the phone with a guy for my home
state and a god I truly am inspired by
and Gary Vee how you doing man we're
doing super well
say hello to Morgan hey we're looking
let's call from your I'm calling from
your hometown of Parkersburg West
Virginia wherever Oh that is where I was
born that's fantastic
I mean this is getting super medic do
you have a question for Gary yes yeah
person Gary I was right by why library
over the last week I was going to stop
in but I'll try stopped in this week
what would I do my business travel okay
so they did not stop in but you still
have a chance to stop in right I do bro
okay like do bro like I expect you to
buy some product oh well Morgan I know
that I know this format Gary thank you
for taking my call I know it's virtually
possible get on Morgan I have a question
for you sir yes sir you know you know
the situation of your home state bro I
mean it's the depressed highest
overdoses of everything a heroin coal
mining industry there's a lot of the
press discourage young people here yeah
what what suggestions would you give so
those in this kind of a market that are
trying to make the creative or
entrepreneurial bark yeah I mean I think
the biggest thing right now is people
and I say this about anything and
whether it's you know storytelling
making movies are starting a starting a
new business is that you you can't be
afraid to take risks and I think that I
we come from a state and we grew up in a
stager up in a state where you know it
is it is very rooted in being risk
averse I think that you like to do what
works we want to stick with what works
you know whether it be the coal industry
or whether it be something else the idea
of trying to you know overturn the apple
cart is scary a lot of times and I think
what happens to happen right now is
there needs to be some real investment
some real invention some real dedication
on bringing new businesses to the state
new opportunities to the state because
this is a state full of people who are
passionate who are hard workers that I
feel like would give 110 percent
whatever that is but people are just you
know whether it be unwilling to come
there or people who live there leave to
go somewhere else probably guy right I
mean I think all of the italic goes to
San Francisco all available talent goes
to LA or you know New York gets
everything there was this thing that
happened a few years ago where I believe
it was when mansion who's now the
senator was the governor and it was like
they changed the slogan to West Virginia
open for business and it was like this
this slogan that I found to be you know
such kind of a catch-22 because they
wanted to bring new business there yet
the ability or potential or I guess the
the flavor desire to invest in new
businesses was so small that it was
really frustrating listen Mel I think
the one thing that everybody has to
understand is you can trick
entrepreneurs that's right
like if I knew that I could open an
office in West Virginia and Morgan's
right now that's right and I could get a
building for free and it's tax free for
five years major media is opening up and
I'm going to recruit everybody from WVU
that's right look tomorrow it's just
math yeah and it's and it's a question
of how much will the state canola will
pay or open their doors have these
business women when these states stop
spending money on dumb [ __ ] yeah that
are inside baseball and servicing other
random stuff and realize that look this
has now been proven over the course of
times you
are financially driven animals there are
a lot of ways they're artistic as well
there are other things that's right but
you know what I love about salespeople
they're trickable yeah I'm very
trickable if the Omaha Nebraska were
Toronto or or you know any place they
heard they know how to pass them
anywhere yeah if somebody wants me I'm
open for business like Saint kun can
email me right now and say look look at
ten million dollars for you and that's
what you actually are supposed to do I
actually think I've been like athletes
yeah like the Cavaliers shucks until
they get LeBron yeah like the Bulls and
Lakers suck right now you know why
there's no kopi or Michael Jordan
walking through those doors yeah if you
want to build up the economy trick the
economic leader entrepreneurs I mean you
can eat look if they pour 25 million
dollars into studios and talent well
this entire week they can trick you to
move you're happy importantly you're
summing up my next point of what I was
going to say this just happened as a
storyteller a filmmaker who's gone back
and shot in West Virginia on at least
six or seven projects I've gone back
home to shoot they've now eliminated the
film office in West Virginia they've cut
it out of the budget they've cut out the
tax incentive for the state so now why
are people like me you're storytellers
there's no incentive now to come back
and and they're pay back so much and
they're going to commit and they're
continuing to cut kind of this type of
economic influence in the state not just
from filmmaking but just from new
business startups so I would answer
something more practical for your
question about there's obviously the
state so the answer is the state has to
get involved state has I get emporia
like that's your Andrus so you know yeah
now the second thing of what you can do
is groom extremely young talent that's
right the one thing like human can do is
focus on junior high and high school and
create mentorship and like little hacks
like the reason I created 2017 flip
challenge is like I want to inspire
people like that didn't have as many
dollars to start or as many
opportunities to start like you've got a
hack at a lower level you're not going
to start you're not sending Morgan a
heartfelt email that's going to make him
pick up his family from Brooklyn and
move that's right so you've got to start
with Morgan 13 years old who's like oh
[ __ ] I can make something or I can do a
thing like a mail you can email YouTube
and Vimeo and other cut like there's a
lot there just pure effort
hacking but it's reverse-engineering
selfishness yeah and the things like I
go back and and you know I get
approached all the time to do things
back home but I think in terms of
entrepreneurship and building businesses
they have to incentivize they have
people to come so I'm gonna look there's
nonprofit and that's why you've done it
right they're nonprofit I do a lot of
things out of the goodness of my heart I
just think that the way to trick me is
through the business and the game not
through you got a trick through the the
head and the brain not just the heart
the heart is Abel Morgan's going to do a
shitload for West Virginia when he's 80
and he's got it out of his system like
oh yeah I understand that's real that's
real it's easier at different parts in
your life when you're still gunning like
you know it's you give and plenty people
give while they're gunning but it's just
a lot easier to give gift yeah when
you're not gunning yeah and I think
that's super important that's like
that's why people teach that's why she's
gonna teach this year she's 74 she's
done gunning she like and so I think I
think that's something you got you got
to be very practical my man understood
sure hey Gary Vee thank you so much your
money I bought you I bought crush it at
a bookstore that no longer exists when
it came out here in West Virginia been a
follower ever since man thanks for the
inspiration you got my life thank you
bye thank you so much thankful man he
really drilled it at the end right he
was like bought from a bookstore doesn't
exist anymore put a real dagger through
like this it's really ironic a lot of
Jersey kids now my entire high school
friend circle 60% of them went to West
Virginia which is ironic and so and also
the New York Jets
grab the Gino Smith I know so Anthony I
was so hopeful and that happened yeah me
too
I was I was believing and Anthony Becht
tight end first-round pick from West
Virginia I've got a lot of love for West
Virginia ready rembert yeah if you want
to go back old school I'm gonna let who
we call now
Kimberly about to point out Oh Kimberly
this is Gary be in your knee askgaryvee
show with Morgan oh my god I can't
believe it
awesome awesome awesome Marriott we're
we're good well where you from I'm from
you
in Texas very nice what's your question
so my question is I'm a writer and a
poet and I the part I struggle with is
monetizing myself I'm very creative I
would like to say that I am excellent at
putting out content I'm documenting
myself I have no problem being in front
of my iPhone at any given time I'm
always writing I'm always creating every
day and so my question is though I
struggle with okay I'm doing all this
great work or you know making my work
I'm putting it out there but how do I
make a living at this in in a in a big
way or how do i monetize because I like
being the creative and not so good at
being the one that you know yeah I mean
Kim Kim this is literally the most
cliche story of our time yeah artists
versus business person and the artists
that tend to break out either have the
businessperson partner or they happen to
have business DNA as well you know
artists that everybody knows are
stunningly sales people and marketers
and various people very savvy a hundred
percent yeah Morgan I'm going to let you
take the first crack at this because
this must be so cliche this is literally
everybody you grew up with Oh innocence
and so many people I meet all the time
it's like how do I just turn this into
you know you and you don't just want a
job and because in the beginning you
want to chip away and you want to get
jobs you want to get people who are
going to pay you to do this thing you
love to do this job but you need to turn
that also into a career you want it to
be something that you're going to get to
do forever so you never have to offset
that with job X or job Y you know you
never have to do something else to kind
of offset the income but in the
beginning the biggest thing is you
should take as many jobs as you can as
much as you can that is in this space
that doesn't mean you can't still be
doing other things but as a writer and
as a creative person you need to be
doing as many things as you can to kind
of fulfill that creative quote unquote
job for yourself and and you shouldn't
be doing them and there's a lot of
people who say well you can't really pay
you you shouldn't do those jobs for free
you know unless it's something like you
really feel like that is great or it's a
great opportunity then
you can do those for free but I think
you have to limit the amount of like the
ones you do for nothing because the more
you start doing really creative or
artistic jobs were freedom where people
are going to expect that you'll do them
for free I think you have to start to
build kind of a responsibility to
yourself as a creative person to start
getting paid for the work you do and you
care about but I think I think that's
right and I think that the reality is
there's one other variable which is I
think the majority of artists out there
need to start thinking about a partner
who owns 20 to 50% of their lives yeah
like especially yeah - how long have you
done this I've been writing I've been
writing off my whole life I've been
serious about it as far as putting stuff
out there for about five years
right so super serious about it for six
months okay so I think that's this point
it sounds like yourself but like if
you're an eighteen year old kid and
you're not sure you don't give up you
know don't let me come in and take 50%
of the action because I figured it out
and you didn't yet but it sounds like
you're already at a point in your life
where it would be a dream to be 50/50
partners with me or 20%
somebody owns 20% who's the salesperson
yeah I am just stunned by how many
artists haven't figured out that they
have zero chance unless they bring in a
business partner and it's the kind of
business when you have no money you're
not paying some business kid
you know 150,000 to be your business
partner you're going to have to give up
economics sweat equity and there's a guy
and by the way now let's reverse it so
everybody doesn't think this is the
business guy talking yeah the amount of
business people probably way more
watching and listening right now the
amount of business people who can't
build an interesting product
yeah or we'll have nothing worth selling
there ever in their lives is stunning
there's a lot and they're a lot better
to find an artist who makes great [ __ ]
yeah and make 50% of that so it's
amazing to me that the artist and the
business sales person have such an
incredible match yet they're both
stubborn in getting to that middle place
because sales people are selling dog
[ __ ] and I mean and artists are making
incredible [ __ ] but nobody's ever going
to see it because they can't sell for
WIC Yeah right yeah how do I find that
person because everything and everything
everything you do right now should be
about that you should go to the Chamber
of Commerce events yeah where there's
business people at
post on social media should be I'm
looking because you know your college
friends brother or sister might be that
great but your behavior has to show that
everything you care about right now is
finding that part of you thinking it
yeah in Houston Texas there that person
is there Houston is a big enough city
filled with enough book creative and
business minded folks that you can find
that person who will be there complement
you and all day and Gary's right like
I've got a business partner who started
off thirteen years ago as my assistant
like right after was super sizing me
came out in theaters and now together
he's my partner I've got another partner
now at my company there's three of us
and we've grown our company to now
sixty-five people's so I think that you
have to you have to look at what you're
willing to grow what you're willing to
sacrifice and what it can turn into yeah
absolutely I'm like hey come along with
me whatever we can sell together then
yeah you get a piece of it you know I'm
not like sitting there going you know
trying to count my pennies but how
aggressive have you been in trying to
find that person for real don't [ __ ]
Morgan oh I I have it because literally
the idea is it's not that with me but I
always felt like it I wasn't a good
entrepreneur if I was I was being a
crybaby if I wanted to have a partner no
no it's also great realizing it's also
great realizing you can't do it and do
everything like I'm a great creative
person I understand business I'm a great
salesperson but at some point you do
need somebody to help you if you really
want to create something that can scale
and grow yeah yeah I mean
entrepreneurship is about winning at all
costs fairly in a wide-open game that's
right partnerships are a huge part of
that it's having the humility and
self-awareness
I'm glad you go so real quick what's
your email my email is can block
beauties at Kim Black Beauty Bar at
gmail.com okay good pretty podcast
that's going to be do good luck but for
the show we're going to get that email
from Jake you're gonna figure that out
one more time like let's really get that
email you've got the info we're going to
put that email here you're about to get
seven hundred and thirteen emails from
business sales people spend a month
interview and Skype and call with all of
them and you will literally have a
business partner in the next thirty days
awesome
take care thanks think she was gonna say
she's so [ __ ] pumped where she was oh
right I think that's what we had so
while I am he's pulling up the next
number
Sundance yeah you can taste it on day
two also so here's the thing to the
movie the movie took off the movie
exploded out of Sundance and somebody
stops me at the Film Festival it was it
was a it was a it was a movie reviewer
named James Rocchi who he said so and
and now go back like I grown up my whole
life watching Sundance yeah that's where
people came into these the festival with
these little movies that nobody had
heard of that literally changed their
life forever so whether you're the Coen
brothers whether you're Kevin Smith
you're Quentin Tarantino you're Robert
Rodriguez you know I you know you've
been watching this my whole life so
suddenly I'm there in 2004 and James
Rocchi comes up to me he says so how
does it feel to be the belle of the ball
and I'm like what are you talking about
and he goes this is yours is your
Sundance mr. Spurlock and at that moment
like I'm getting chills just right now
telling you this story because at that
moment I realized holy [ __ ] I'm that guy
I'm the guy I'm Cinderella I'm the guy I
am the guy who came in with the movie I
made for nothing who's going to walk out
of here in my life's never going to be
the same you know it right and it was it
hit me at that moment like that's that's
this and I what happened right that's
what happened my life give me a like
give me the next minute what happens
next day like they're just getting
pounded counted with press pounded with
opportunities pounded with phone calls
cool is the coolest phone call you got
who is the coolest phone call I don't
know I mean I got called by a lot of
movie studios which is a young filmmaker
you know just stream dream like when
Studios are calling you saying we want
to come can you come meet with us and
you know what's great about social media
now yeah like and this was again this
was no sorry media back that's only now
is like some of you were famous just
tweets like oh my god this film was
incredible you didn't like all the
famous people you looked up to I didn't
actually really know I never got to you
that's right they thought your film was
awesome until I would like see them
somewhere or meet people somewhere and
it was pretty pretty made so much weight
did you gain again 26 pounds over the
course of a month oh I can gain that
over across a weekend I don't think that
much now in hindsight now that I'm older
I don't like I was slacking I did you
lose it how to code took me over a year
to get it off and keep it off because
losing it's easy keeping it off as the
hard part yeah I do love chicken nuggets
man
I love I just love I just love Fried
Chicken period yeah I get it
oh yeah Justin hey Justin Gary B on the
askgaryvee show with Morgan Spurlock how
are you good um okay I I'm running out
of ideas I just wanted to see what your
thoughts are if you're running if you're
- if you were given a a client that
they've run a campaign for us for a
luxury underwear company okay so are you
on the creative side we're on the media
amplification side or both where are you
sitting oh right so I didn't I think I
think and this is men's or women's or
it's it's men and women even though I
think there's a bigger market for
women's are starting with men so
starting with men yep okay I would hang
up the phone right now and I would
direct message every dude on instagram
that has 500,000 followers or more and
tell them that you need to blow up this
underwear brand what do they want okay
that's it bro and I'm telling you right
now now you'll get blocked after a
certain amount then you'll go to Twitter
this is literally hardcore knocking on
doors good-looking dude models on
Instagram athletes even comedians even
non good-looking dudes wearing that
underwear the exposure for the cost is
so low and it's instant instant impact
on the brand make sure the URL on the
Instagram account is linking to the cart
make sure your your make sure their
Instagram accounts of this brand has 15
to 20 pieces of content on it that
looked the part looks right and then you
just literally bizdev your job here is
to be the architect of the success not
the creative director or the media
planner this is literally just siphoning
the underpriced nature of personal
brands on Instagram which is very visual
this is underwear this is a [ __ ]
layup and when you ask them what they
want they're pretty much gonna say to
give me free free underwear no they're
gonna ask you for [ __ ] money bro so
what you need to figure out is how much
money you have now if you hit up
somebody who's extremely good-looking
but doesn't have a big audience like
and if you'd up Andy Andy how many
followers you have on Instagram and your
Verity and you're very good-looking um
oh yeah that's right so all right so how
many followers you have on Instagram
yeah I got me like 18,000 granny you're
huge so more is the perfect example of
who not to hit up under Fame you know
he's too famous for the reach he has on
Instagram so he's not going to take four
bucks to post in underwear right and and
look I nobody wants to see me anywhere
that's very nice I think I need have a
mix of like Ronaldo and like Jake right
like we have to mix it up right like
well that's not that's what I think I
think you should find I think you should
find some of the people who are the
least attractive people on Instagram and
you also get them underwear and by the
way and I have a nephew this campaign be
like we all want we all want to feel
good naked and yeah because we all are
we all gonna feel good in our underwear
as long as that person has a ton of
followers that's right right so like to
me I agree like I think you should go to
anybody if they have a hundred million
followers the problem is they're going
to ask for money so the question is do
you have any if you don't we've got to
change it up again which is if you want
to be successful for this brand you can
hit them up and say hey man we working
with this one client I love for you to
post you have eighty-seven thousand
followers I'd love you to post on the
flipside I'll make three pieces of
content for you for your account you got
to be a trade legend about trades right
we started with this with the state
whether it's the state and a person
whether it's two people with a business
in the middle it's all about trades and
so you need to figure out the influencer
market on Instagram the price the value
because that's where the action is
especially for something as visual as an
underwear brand how much money do you
want to wear the underwear I've never
done a brand deal in my entire life so
whatever the current value of the New
York Jets is so for 2.1 billion dollars
I'll wear that underwear for rest of my
life but look at it's ironic and it's a
great question you're going to make this
piece of content more valuable
I don't do brand stuff because I've
decided to build an agency I've done
other things so like everybody's got
their own thing right like there's a lot
but for example let me give a good one
Braxton Miller Jalen reeves-maybin John
Toth guys that work at Bay
Sport guys that are signed to Vayner
sports because I so desperately want
them to be successful and to show the
sports world that I'm good
I would do something maybe I would be in
the video of the producing of the video
commercial for Braxton in his underwear
which then I could share on my channels
there's a way to get me literally the
answer to your question is probably
$500,000 because a million-dollar man's
right right everybody's got a price
right but by the way I'm not even
remotely close to 500,000 but if you
gave but if you gave one of my athletes
35 K I'd probably give you the same
amplification because I need that to
work so now look those are big numbers
you're probably dealing with a smart up
startup so you have to go to people that
want 500 bucks 100 bucks a thousand a
free lunch some free content yes and so
maybe you're not going to get people
with millions but guess what seven
thousand here nine thousand there and
what one thing I would highly recommend
is attractive people attractive people
is an arbitrage in life if you're
good-looking life is better so you might
be able to get somebody who has 6,000
followers who's really really good a
really good looking and it just might
have the right 6,000 people paying
attention to that dude and so you're
gonna have to get educated on it but the
macro answer is Instagram influencers I
know that for a fact you just have to
build up your skills on it got it yep
got it thank you sir you got a brother
all right let's get one more
well Morgan finishes off this super
that's what happened next what was the
project after that so that blew up you
became a big deal everybody knows who
you are now what happens this leads me
to something else that I I think that
what people also have to understand
about whether it's creative process of
running a business is you should always
you need to be playing chess and not
checkers you need to be 16 moves ahead
you need to have a sense of this isn't
what I'm doing next is what I'm doing
next is what I want to do after that
what I'm doing after that you need to
have the things in the pipeline lined up
behind whatever this thing that explodes
is so you're prepared to react and so on
the heels of us selling supersize me out
of Sundance we already knew what was
next we went to LA I already knew we
were spending this off into a TV show we
wanted to make a show where we could
immerse people into these different
environments and forced them to kind of
defend their beliefs and that show
became 30 days the show that we did
three seasons up for Netflix it was
amazing but but we literally went from
Sundance the next week and sold that
show to FX before the movie was ever out
before you know it ever hit theaters and
it was it was smart but we kind of had a
we had a path of what we wanted our what
I wanted my career kinda the next
creative process to be what's the
project you really want to do that
hasn't that you haven't gotten off the
ground yet ya know there's got three
fourths of it in your head yeah there's
a couple what's floating in that brain
of yours you know we there's a couple
big there's a couple big projects like
there's a couple big scripted projects
that we've been dancing around that
knock on wood we'll be able to pull off
like for me to do a big scripted film
would be phenomenal to do a big
narrative film and what kind of genre I
mean I think that a comedy snob I love
and I love I love sci-fi but I think the
first path in for us before I can do
like the big sci-fi that I would love to
make is I want to do something that's a
bit more of a bit more of a comedy like
a drum like a dramedy some of the ideals
but so this I think historical in nature
like I right now there's a movie that uh
that I hope we can pull off that is all
about it's based on a book called
ping-pong diplomacy that's all about how
in the 70s cool yeah it's like this
amazing film how in the sciences of all
about China in the US and how literally
a ping-pong tournament yeah was let up
in ping-pong 100% opened us-china
relations I love that it's awesome
that's cool and then you want to do Star
Wars 29 now apparently the Han Solo job
has got pills Ronnie Ronnie Ronnie
Ronnie
we get Ronnie a little bit in some weird
way oh yeah you have Ronnie like can't
we record yeah we're both like you know
just this like wine gingers soon I mean
that Ronnie I have a bit more hair than
he does I just met him like a like a
couple let's go nice tunic dude he's a
Grey's like such a great guy knife yeah
he and I had a oh oh hello hey this is
very beyond the askgaryvee show and Andy
doesn't know your name who are you yeah
I'm a I can't believe this
my name is talk to open dilemma from
former Soviet country as well
you can call me feel no problem how are
you is all you want I wanna make sure I
hear this right okay what what can we
call you bill bill or get Gil
Gilmore bill GI l or B I ll be I ll let
me write more to you right one-zero gary
bill first of all you know i've got a
tough name your name is incredible and i
appreciate
being able to call you bill and I will
practice to call you by your appropriate
name where are you now
I'm accidentally yep all it's Minnesota
very nice so from the former Soviet
Union like me in Minnesota now what is
your question my friend my impression I
know your quote
yeah you actually what are you doing
yeah no no do it if we appointed we need
an approach first or your impression on
us and then a question I want both the
impression and the question okay so I
know man so I'm from Mongolia farmer so
a country as well and Gary you are
becoming a very big configure in
Mongolia as well so like today is
actually a big day is happening in
Mongolia today is a presidential
election and Mongolians are tending to
be true of course where you entrepreneur
yeah this is in yes first time yes and I
would say like you had a great impact on
that as well because like lots of
Millennials have been like introducing
you to their audience in Mongolia so
will not build oh we go any further I
just want to make sure I quantify this
are you saying that I'm having an impact
on the Mongolian presidential election
right now yes but I but minimum Allah is
like a Inc
I appreciate you but I'm stunningly
flattered even though having a point
zero zero zero zero zero zero one
percent Yujin Mongol I appreciate it
bill thank you for that and your
question for Morgan and I well you have
depression I'm an international student
from Mongolia and usually like state
zero I'm an international student visa
yes so if you if you can say I actually
have like a less right than legal
immigrant in some situations so what
would be your suggestion to
international student who is trying to
start his business in United States but
trying to not just be restricting the
United States but also in Mongolia and
the United States like have tried to
have a connection
yeah I think I think there's so I think
you take advantage of the time that
you're here
and you and you do practical things not
romantic things now I wouldn't force
what I'm about to say but it would be
the thing that would be on my mind my
second day my scuse me my first day of
high school there's a kid in my homeroom
named Brandon Warneke who I hit it off
with actually I laughed I laughed at the
way they pronounced his name and then
everybody laughed so he hated me for the
first day but later we became very good
friends and literally literally I knew
that I was looking for a business
partner in my future my freshman year of
high school and to this day here we are
27 years later and Brandon Warneke runs
the wine library with my dad so so what
I would say is while you're here finding
somebody that you trust that could
become your business partner if the
circumstances don't allow you to stay
here in the u.s. that could hold down us
operations would be my number one I
would literally meet people meet people
at scale every second meeting people
that would be the two things I would try
to do if I were you based on the
question is learn the American culture
of business and the marketing and me and
as many people as possible who could be
future collaborators weather is extreme
as a business partner or just business
connections for the next 80 years
welcome no that's that's a great
suggestion because I when I look at my
like my the film business says is just
the investment business it's a very
incestuous universe like people go from
job to job to job and it becomes a as
big as you think the pool is it does
become a much smaller pool of people who
really have control and influence and
can help shape things and the more you
people meet the people now that are
within these positions are that are kind
of on the hockey stick up you meet them
they're kind of on a track to to become
a manager here bran this side of a
division here invest here like like
identifying those people now as they
will continue to grow in those
opportunities are going to be the people
that five years from now ten years from
now are going to be the people that are
be running the companies you want to
work with and and I love all the time
how many of the people that I start out
in the film business now that are that
are really players players players at
agencies players of studios Yeltsin Carl
life life is only about relationships
and it's compounded in former
dictatorships and communist countries
where relationship is the currency you
know here here back to
any head earlier today where he said it
was amazing about America is no matter
where your family start he said whether
slavery or immigration somewhere
eventually in your family line there is
an opportunity West Virginia is not the
hotbed right so we bill I would say
you've got to triple down on your
relationship investment as many people
as you can meet as many the Chamber of
Commerce in Minnesota meet up calm every
Minnesota meet up that has entrepreneurs
and business people go to them shake
hands kiss babies build relationships
Wow okay as ever it's not about that to
be honest not at all and that excites me
and it's funny that I gave you that
advice because it is a very common
cliche stereotypical characteristic of
Eastern European non-us businesspeople
to not be kind of shaking you know we
keep to ourselves in the oak former USSR
right yeah so I gave you that advice
kind of Adam intuition as well I don't
think so
people don't realize how much it's the
people part and not the movie you make
the product you sell the big idea you
come up with it will be I'm really happy
you called and got through because I
think it's great advice for you but I
also think it's great advice for a lot
of people listening and watching alright
wonderful that's incredible thank you so
much Gary and Morgan thank you thank you
an amazing thing
since you are huge in Mongolia we just
made a movie about Mongolia that now
everybody can see it's on came out in
theatres of shortlisted for an Oscar
last year called the Eagle Huntress
which people should watch your being
dead serious
I'm being dead serious we made a movie
it was crew so we produce it was
directed by well you loved it it's a
beautiful movie so it's about this
father who teaches his 13 year old
daughter to become an Eagle hunter if it
is it would it be impactful for you for
it to get a second bump and do well on
like I mean I think listen anytime as I
love when people watch dachshund anybody
watching share Doc's I think it's great
but this just kind of hit iTunes it is
out into the universe
so people should check it out it's
people to me with my newfound massive
leverage yeah in Mongolia yeah can we
make a transaction you're like if I get
7% of the upside on the back end of this
movie thing like do you want to talk to
Sony Pictures clatters somehow it's
better to talk to you Mia all right
we're not gonna do any more cause I
think we did well they're forged you
know given you know you have a lot of
what I would
artistic business-focused people yeah a
lot of people creating content I said
something around documenting versus
creating which I tried to create is a
framework of not crippling people and
just kind of like go
reality TV doc on your phone because
people are stuck yeah in making way
anything you can add to the young
audience right now well one of the
greatest things a photographer friend
I'm the friend of mine said is a
photographer added everybody says like
what's your favorite camera and the in
the answer is whichever one I have in my
hand so I think that no matter what
you're shooting no matter where you are
if the only thing you have to document
whatever you're doing is this to tell a
story with is awesome the amazing thing
is we live in a time now where we used
to be like oh my god it's so shaky
that's all gone like this has all been
flown out the window people don't give a
[ __ ] about quality they don't give a
[ __ ] [ __ ] about how it's edited they
don't get about how it looks they want
to all about read about the story what's
the story you tell me a good story I can
put up with this morning when I when I
launched Wine Library TV yeah in 2006 it
didn't look good no it did not I
remember you remember I do I really
catch a radar dick or makes me happy
yeah um I mean little story of course
people like you look like a hostage in
the Middle East I'm like cool but you
were also a guy who was waxing rhapsodic
about wine in a way that everybody could
finally understand fine I like here you
were here was some guy who wasn't making
me like feel like an idiot for talking
to me about wine in a way that I had to
have a PhD to understand I didn't have
to be a master of wine to watch that
right and I think that's what that's
what was brilliant tell me uh tell me
tell me one last rant because I don't
want to let you go one last thing on
culture moviemaking social media which
give us a couple give us a couple 360
well here's the thing that kind of
Morgan well is for all the storytellers
that are out there no matter who you are
what you're doing now is the greatest
time in the history of our culture in
the history of media and history of
storytelling to be a storyteller period
there are more places to tell your
stories there are more places to sell
your story never stop right there
something there
Hulu Facebook Netflix I mean Amazon you
can say the same you know all I really
like oh my god it's so exciting to
Facebook life it's the countless digital
platforms the fact that I can now tell a
story and reach somebody in the palm of
their hand is exciting to have this
direct one-to-one relationship is
amazing and I can make things now that
are two hours long that I can sell into
a theatrical
I can make things that are one hour long
they can have a traditional television
or digital release or I can make
something that's five minutes long and a
fact and effect and impact somebody in
just the same way in your career and
your balance of your career your family
yeah do you have a little sliver that
you can create to be a little bit more
out there and do a podcast a vlog a QA
show like I was so excited to have you
on there I've had a lot of interesting
different people but I feel like where
are you at with putting yourself out
there and engaging with the audience
where it's you not you're doing some
interviews where do you sit on that
thesis no I think I think that you're
you're hitting the nail in the head is
it for so long I focused on yes our
traditional production and the way we're
doing that this is exactly what's
happening right now
good yeah I'd love to talk to you off
this like I think you guys I can't be a
part of this conference no you guys are
out you got out of that but I wish I
wish you guys could see like the whole
setup is underneath this camera they
have the camera wrapped around a box of
Dom Perignon if that's how Jeremy wrote
Tom there's a box there's a limit I love
the Hammers wrapped around how we roll
my ass back you know king of Mongolia
king among all it's true I am among
those guys really sold on going King
please good historical references yeah
um uh okay and finally we're where are
you now so that's why I asked yeah I
feel like there's a lot of people who
may want to reach out this would be
spring point where is the best place to
kind of if they're going to be able to
capture attention is an email is a
Twitter where I run all my own social
media yes like they can get me through
Instagram where's the real plan to
Twitter it says yes Instagram its
Twitter it's been to in comments will
you see them engage or is it more likely
to hit reply you on Twitter and you like
which one will get you I get I replied
all of them I reply to everyone no
matter where it is
I replied everyone on Facebook on
Twitter and on Instagram get ready my
friend yeah awesome question of the day
question of the day you get to ask the
question of the day every guest on the
show yeah thanks for watching gets to
ask the question of the day yeah
anything you want thousands of answers
fire away thousands of answers are you I
wish I would have known that I could
have found more than research I wish I
could have done a little buddy watch the
show you know
what my question of the day anything you
want I'll give you a second you're a buy
some time sure something you this could
be good messages have to apply to my
line no could be as question about like
do you like oranges or apples better who
are ya if you'd like to be smarter as
you can think about the four to seven
projects that are running through your
head yeah you might be able to get some
consumer insights of scale here yes you
might be able to scratch your itch on
maybe there's a debate that you've had
with your buddy from junior high for the
last 31 years maybe you're a hardcore
reddit fan like and there's something
going to like I don't know yeah what do
you got these are all good questions I
thank you I'm trying to say you I see
but that since you talked about the
podcast maybe that's the question we
should ask
I don't know soul okay I was that if I
was going to do a podcast what should
that podcast be that was a very good
question you tell me love it thank you
my man great to you guy really really
this is a lot going to be awesome
you keep asking questions we'll keep
answering them
[Music]